good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
yeah it is my favorite [ __ ] day of
the week you guys what day is it wait
what was that
it's hump day you would never know it
because the
man of the hour is not here yeah theo's
not here which is usually our um hump
day mascot
i just had some i had a crazy busy
morning you know meetings meetings
meetings meetings meetings meetings all
day
aaron's errands errands and it's like
sometimes being and this is going to be
terrible to say but i know my fellow dog
moms will probably be able to relate to
it
sometimes being a mom has to take a back
seat
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good message bless you and
i sneezed on it which means it's true
yeah no and also theo like he wanted the
day off after his long weekend like he's
just struggling to get back into the
groove
yeah like so many of us yeah but it is
hump day so by the time the show is over
we'll be over the hump which you just
absolutely love to see and by the time
you're done watching this it's probably
lunch time or depending on like where
you live like snack time or maybe even
depending on your schedule like time to
go home so just let this episode carry
you through
the treacherousness but also the joy the
beauty that is hump day because we have
an amazing show of course we've got the
fast five stories and
they're so fast and they're so five
there's definitely
five of them can't deny it no and we
also have
a uh tv recap of real housewives of new
york and i will
really do everything in my power to have
something to say about it because there
was really nothing that really went on
last night except
i think um things might be turning
around
and i think vernon shaw is a good
addition that's where my
rashaan i'm so sorry um i think that's
where my feelings are at
okay cool we'll talk about it agreed not
much to say i'm slowly creeping towards
not watching anymore last night i almost
tried to get away with it but
i realized i did have the time yeah
because i finished my book the lion's
den i finished it at like 10 o'clock
it was so good you have to read it if
you
like you know thriller mystery and
glamour
the lion's den by katherine st john it
was so good like
every i don't want to give i went into
it totally blind so i don't want to give
anything away but i just want to say
like it just it pays off
i'd love to hear that um and then we
also have dear toasters because it's
wednesday we have three brand new
submissions from you guys
and i just love kind of spreading my
gospel
through dear toasters and i'm really
excited about it i'm really excited to
hear what's going on with you guys how
we can help how we can be there for you
and support
um but otherwise it's just another
fabulous day of the toast and
it's olivia's birthday yes our big sis
is turning 30 which means
that's in our future yeah it's crazy
when the first one turns 30. like that's
about to be us
that's crazy stuff not to make olivia's
birthday like about me
no not at all but i would never but like
you're me
never no never no but it is your
birthday soon yes so
it is and following up from yesterday's
episode um
i did sort of figure out what i wanted
to do for my birthday i'm about halfway
there so
if you haven't received an invitation
and you think that you deserve to
please reach out to me because i
probably just forgot no ill will
no ill will okay cool maybe some but no
but if you have club's number
you have my number and like you want to
come to my birthday party like just make
sure you text me because i
i'm planning it all very like
haphazardly yeah and it's really not
like uh
i'm not trying to be mean i just like
probably forgot that's pretty mean also
though
yeah and i'm not gonna lie like maybe
some of you i was trying to be mean and
maybe some of you are forgettable
yeah and that's kind of on you not on me
i'm just a human okay within a ready
impaired memory right and all ready to
go ahead and be forgettable towards a
girl
who can't even remember you're setting
yourself up for failure and again
that's on you yeah but again if you find
yourself constantly being forgotten
text me don't forget it's really sweet
of you claude so i do what i can still
make
i do what i can for the people thank you
well we're excited to celebrate your
birthday too we all want to celebrate
each other's birthday i think we
all have birthdays this week but we do
want to wish olivia a very happy
birthday you know there's a chance that
she watches this because sometimes she
does
no because she's actually a supportive
sister right sometimes she doesn't but
sometimes she does so maybe she'll tune
in today wondering if we're going to
like
give her a birthday shout out happy
birthday liv we love you so much like
miss k his mom everything of the sort
you're the best like thank you for the
pleasure of making us aunties
thank you for bestowing the honor upon
us of being aunties
and also just like popping out like the
most premium kid like i'm sure
everyone's kid is great and beautiful
yeah but they're not kayla
no no they're not oh and that's a fact
yeah and that's on what
period that's an actual fact yeah no
it's not an opinion
it's a fact no but that harks back to
yesterday's story actual facts
oh right yeah that was a dark story i
liked it
i enjoyed every moment i get to spend
with you i didn't hear anything from the
toasters
one way or the other and no news is good
news and i'm gonna take the win i
couldn't agree more like sometimes it's
nice to just like talk about
nonsense because like i don't really
feel
like sometimes having an opinion because
then like i just have to deal with like
people like
telling me that i'm wrong yeah also but
in the words of tamara judge
that's my opinion we talk about so much
nonsense the least we could do is like
switch up the nonsense in which we're
talking about
business nonsense business nonsense and
also
just having different conversations you
know yeah nor like normalize having
different conversations normally
switching it up
switching it up well i think we have
like a nice mix today
actually i'm really excited about the
stories today a lot a lot to chat about
so i think without further ado
do where are you not here obviously we
should get into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
um and i don't really have a savvy
transition for today's uh
oh my god i'm kidding i'm not going to
be annoying today's episode is brought
to you by is everything okay
no i'm really stressed like my birthday
is really stressful yeah are you really
yes because like okay sorry sorry
sorry manscape just give me one minute
because like
and this is the thing with birthdays we
spoke about this yesterday like the
older you get the more dumb you feel
and then i was like really hell bent on
having a party
and i know like these are not real
problems so don't like come at me i'm
just
expressing my feelings on my podcast and
if you don't like it you are more than
welcome to leave
there's millions of others they're not
as good but have fun
so they're not daily they enjoy no and
like they don't try as hard as we do but
fine have a good time
they're not sisters they don't have a
preacher
they're not available a lot in spotify i
students stitcher okay
i'm done um so i was like i really want
to have a party and then when i made the
decision to have a party and started
sending out invitations i'm like wow i
wish i wasn't having this party because
like you know three people said they
couldn't come and i'm like okay nobody's
coming and then i just got like a little
insane like inviting people i've never
met like on instagram
you got desperate wow right is that what
you're saying
i don't know if i would say you just
said inviting people on instagram which
actually makes me think
not what i thought you were gonna say
which is like three people couldn't come
so you started inviting
you guys you said i haven't gone to tier
b yeah so you didn't get desperate you
got it i'm
getting there ambitious i got ambitious
i just wanted to be like a fabulous
party and there's so many people like
that i talked about instagram who yes
i've never met but i think they should
come to my fabulous birthday party i
agree that's how instagram works yeah so
now
i'm just like not that girl you know so
i'm like having a lot of anxiety like
you know
are people gonna think it's weird like
that i invited them even though i've
never met them
i don't think so think about being in
the other person's shoes say this person
that you you know
communicate with on instagram i wouldn't
think if they invited you to a party you
would be nothing but flattered
okay i wouldn't think it's weird right
and but like if they don't come like
i'll be sad
but don't take it personally okay okay
no i just don't like having anxiety
because like i'm a grown woman having a
stupid birthday party and
that's kind of my cross to bear yeah and
but you made this choice for yourself
thank you for reminding me of that i
know and like the thing is about choices
stick with them like oh i can't have
confidence
i have no courage of my convictions like
confidence in your party
i'll try we'll invite some people sure
okay no like whenever i'm having an
event
and i need people to show up like jackie
just taps in you know in that scene in
legally blonde where like
all the delta new sisters like it's like
a million boxes and it's like four girls
call four girls and then it's like
eight thousand people show up at the
capitol or whatever that is the colgate
network by jackie i need some people to
fill up this party so i want to look
like a loser and she invites everyone
she invites like one person from college
and then they all show up so
i'll let you know if i need the colgate
security line emergency reserves
literally i'll let you know okay cool
but today's episode i digress is brought
to you by manscaped the sun's out so
that means bums are out and it's time
for hot girl summer
is your man ready to join the heat with
you make sure he has the right tools to
look and feel his best
our friends at manscaped have him
covered they've just launched their 4th
generation performance package and their
sheers 2.0 nail grooming kit
perfect for you or your man 2 million
men worldwide trust manscaped and
have joined them in the manscaped
movement by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with the code
toast manscaped is everything whether
it's your boyfriend your husband or it's
for yourself like
it is it's hot girl summer and it's not
cool like not cool to not be manscaped
or womanscape whatever you want to call
it just like get your
area in check and it's such a good gift
for a husband
we both got our husbands like the whole
kit kit
like eight months ago and first of all i
use it a lot and ben is
obsessed with it the products are really
good and like the um aesthetic the
aesthetic yeah
the leather um travel case it comes in
is great for ben when he travels because
usually he uses like one of my pink
pouches and then all of the products
like look uniform and like i have my own
vibe going on on my side of this thing
but it's nice to see like my man have
his own vibe as well manscape just
vibes you up they even throw in two free
gifts for their performance package 4.0
the manscaped boxers and the shed travel
bag
the travel bag is you can't miss it um
you can bring his good and boys comfort
this summer to the next
level if you've been shaving with the
same nut trimmer on your face
you've been doing it wrong ladies make
it right for them and you with the new
lawnmower 4.0
and get 20 off and free shipping with
the code toast at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code toast at manscaped.com
feel sexy this summer with manscaped
love it thank you for that claudia now i
feel prepared to go into our first story
of the day which is some happy couple
news the only story
i'm not sure if you've seen this but you
probably have um page six reports that
olivia rodrigo is dating producer
adam fayes yes i did see a tick tock
like
when you're on tick tock you're just
kind of above and like way ahead of the
news
yes so in my imo this is some
old hcn nonetheless i'll still discuss
it
um i saw a video of them at disney world
and they were like being cute and there
was actually like a lot of couple
news that came out of that disney world
trip because
they say that demi lovato was there with
noah cyrus and that
the two of them have been rumored to be
a couple oh interesting
yeah and then this is where olivia
rodrigo and her man's just kind of
blew the whole story open got it and
also travis and courtney were at disney
yes yes yes with the kids
and so i guess disney is where you go if
you want to take your relationship
public the driver's license singer is
dating hollywood producer adam phase
page success confirmed
the couple stepped out together at the
space jam a new legacy premiere at party
at six flags magic mountain in
california
last week the singer and production
company must be nice co-founder have
known each other
for years and began as friends they're
told so a lot of the
rhetoric i'm seeing online is people
concerned about their age difference
he's 24 she's 18. and i don't know i'm a
little like i'm a square sometimes but
like
i don't think this is a big deal no this
is not the worst
like we've seen this is not a million
scott and i just feel like
anything remotely less than that should
be applauded
it should be applauded because we know
how bad it could be yeah i guess they're
just like concerned because age was so
much of a factor in her previous
relationship that we now know like how
toxic it was and how bad it ended
but honestly like i when i saw that the
age difference maybe i'm just like jaded
now
i really didn't think it was that big of
a deal like 24 year olds are really
young
i agree and when i first saw
of course when i saw she was dating
someone the first thing i went to look
was his age because
she's so young and i don't think it's
like the craziest age gap but i will say
there's a huge difference between an 18
year old
and a 24 year old like yes
fundamentally but i do think that
and again this is maybe just me making
excuses and but i really do genuinely
genuinely believe that olivia rodrigo is
not like an average 18 year old she's
so successful and like when you grow up
in the spotlight like you do
age faster you are more wise for the
most part not everyone but she
definitely gives me that vibe of a girl
like wise beyond her years like in the
way that she writes and just like
she really is very mature so i don't
know maybe i'm just making excuses for
it but
honestly every time i remember she's 18
i'm shocked yeah
i would agree with you that being in the
spotlight especially after the year
she's had like she's definitely
an older 18 year old but you know what i
was just thinking about recently i don't
know why i was thinking about this when
you go to college
yes a lot of freshmen i went to college
i was 17
which is actually i just have a late
birthday but still i was 17 when i went
to college and then there are seniors in
college
who are 22. yeah and like
they're all together yeah and i was just
like wow that's kind of crazy you could
be
i won't i won't say 17 because um most
people most people are like
18 and you like if a freshman on a
senior date like nobody's like this
age difference is inappropriate yeah and
it's 18 22 23
and this kind of feels similar to that
that's a good call like she's just a
freshman in college and he's just a
senior he's a super senior though
yeah he like went to the navy and he had
to delay a few years he's in a fifth
year yeah
yeah or he couldn't get enough credits
to graduate yeah for sure he can't let
the dream die yeah so i don't know it
wasn't my first thought i will say if
that guy was dating a freshman i would
think it was a little weird
i actually would too i guess i mean when
i first saw it i really didn't think
much of it and then people started
talking about it i'm like yeah i guess
like six years
is is a lot for someone who's 18. it's
not a lot when it's like oh i'm 26 and
this person's 32. it just depends on
like what stage of your life those are
really formative years
yeah but i also kind of like trust
olivia rodrigo if that makes sense
like i trust that she's making the right
decisions you know yeah and if they've
been friends for a while that's always a
good place to start
and i just will say like compared to
some of the other age differences that
we've seen like on the
on the on the scale of what's concerning
like this isn't
up there no like you know how at the
beach they have different colored flags
for like how crazy the ocean is
yeah and i think like the lowest one is
like yellow like this is a yellow flag
there's maybe some concern but i
wouldn't be true i would say lowest is
green
oh i just made that up i don't know the
actual colors i don't imagine green is
like so good yeah
oh wait like a stop light and then
yellow and then orange and then red yeah
that's actually really good
but i agree it's a yellow yeah and we
need to be worried about the reds
yeah the amelia's and the scots yeah
agreed
okay so i'm happy for that she's in a
relationship um
you had previously said that you thought
some of her music was just limiting in
the sense that she didn't have so much
to write about because it's true she's
so young she's only had one relationship
and it's like
honestly at some point we are going to
get tired about hearing about the same
relationship so i'm hoping this just
breaks open a whole new catalog of music
for her i totally agree new ideas new
fights
new arguments new romance new feelings
yeah
yeah i agree i think and she's
definitely like a romantic
you know so i'm happy to see her in a
happy couple relationship
and speaking of happy couple news that
we didn't report on and i want to talk
about why we didn't
tom holland and zendaya have confirmed
themselves as a couple they were spotted
like making out in a car and i think
there's just been rumors about them
forever
okay um and i saw some people commenting
and dming yesterday i can't believe you
talk about tom holland
because i guess like that picture of
them kissing was like the confirmation
the world needed and so many people
stand them
okay and let me say i just i actually
have something embarrassing to admit
i don't really know who he is same okay
like i am
truly a pop culture connoisseur like you
there is not one celebrity like
you cannot quiz me on and like dead ass
like who the [ __ ] is tom holland he's
spiderman
yeah i just get him confused with like
all the other superheroes and like tom
hiddleston
there are so many spider-men no but
what's interesting about this couple is
two things
one he is not zac efron and that means
zenday and zac efron aren't together
and that's really hard for us to digest
and i think that's subconsciously why we
didn't want to talk about it
because we do ship a hundred percent and
two um
one notable thing about this
relationship is that she's like a foot
taller than him
and i just kind of love to see you know
our girls and day breaking the norms you
know
yeah breaking with tradition i agree
love to see it
i'll have to uh study up on his work
yeah i just know there are a lot of
people who are obsessed
captain america like this is just not
our genre
i actually think if you've listened to
the show long enough you know that like
we are truly experts in all things pop
culture
with just a small like in our venn
diagram of things we know the one thing
that gets left out is superhero movies
like we can't tell chris evans from
chris pine or chris
hemsworth pratt whatever we can't tell
the chris is a part i've never seen one
of those movies
and i just honestly choose to be left
out of that narrative it's just not
where i want to be
yeah no it's a literal whole world that
you can't just like
yeah you can't know a little bit about
like you either are all in or you're all
out and unfortunately
we don't have the time but i do think a
lot of people's ships like were
pulled into the harbor when this news
broke so i just wanted to congratulate
those people even though we are not one
of them we do support you and we love to
see
ships being built and prospering a
hundred percent
are you ready for our next story it's a
little biz news from kim kardashian
oh we've ate yeah
kim kardashian is shutting down kkw
beauty to launch quote a completely new
brand
on tuesday she announced that she'll be
shutting down kkw beauty next month
in order to relaunch the line under a
completely new brand to our loyal
customers it all started with the
contour kit and expanded to eyes lips
body and many incredible collections
over the past four years can i just say
when she released a statement it really
made it seem like she was shutting down
kkw
permanently so many thoughts and i think
i actually have a little like
information that might clear something
she said on august 1st at midnight we'll
be shutting down the kkkwbeauty.com site
so we that we can come back to you under
a completely new brand with new formulas
that are more modern innovative and
packaged in an elevated and sustainable
new look
i'm excited to continue to develop and
expand my product range and for you to
finally be able to experience it in the
way that i've always envisioned
in addition my team is hard at work to
improve the customer shopping
experiences we
will be able to purchase my beauty and
cosmetic offerings in all categories
from one single
website it's oh okay well it's important
to note that kylie cosmetics just did
something very similar a lot of people
didn't even notice that like the
instagram got wiped a few months ago and
they haven't been selling anything the
website yeah
the website has been down so uh we
talked about it briefly i thought she
was relaunching as like a
kylie beauty and it was gonna have more
categories it's actually way
more boring than that it from what i
heard and i don't know if this is true
allegedly
when they did their deals yes they're
all involved in a lawsuit
kim is involved in a lawsuit with cody
and separately
kylie is involved in a lawsuit with cody
from their previous manufacturer
yes and in the deal that they did they
gave away their formulas yes which
belonged to colourpop that initial
manufacturer yes and so
i don't know where they're at now with
cody but basically they couldn't be
selling those formulas anymore so they
reformulated everything
in order to get away from the legal
trouble
and they did kind of mask it as this
rebrand we're going to be more
sustainable our packaging is going to be
different we're going to have new logos
kim wants everything
and all of that probably is happening
but the reason the motivation behind
both of their sites just randomly
shutting down during the same time
is because of this lawsuit and it's very
litigious and i don't really understand
it but they both kind of did the same
thing in their deals with cody was that
they sold their formulas but their
formulas belonged
to the initial factory that was helping
them make it i forget i don't know the
name
um and that's illegal so they're both
being sued
by this old manufacturer them and cody
in two separate lawsuits
so they had to immediately stop using
that formula to make money which is why
they reformulated everything which takes
a lot of time
which is why kylie was out of commission
for a few months and july 15th she's
back
yes also but what's interesting about
the kim piece is her saying that it's
going to be
a completely new brand i'm sure she's
taking the w out yes
now this will have like her kkw beauty
her fragrances like ever because she had
it should have always been that she has
a lot of categories so i'm sure it'll
just be like kim kardashian beauty
yeah because there shouldn't be
different websites for the fragrances
for the makeup it
kind of makes no sense and i also feel
the same way about kylie skinning kylie
um yeah it should just be kylie beauty
yeah so we'll see july 15th if kylie
is gonna bring everything into one place
as she should yeah
but does that get [ __ ] up with cody
does cody own fragrance does cody own
kylie skin
no because they have to use kkkw beauty
and they bought kylie cosmetics so they
have to be separate websites
because they're two separate companies
or they're breaking with cody
no no no no but they're in a lawsuit how
do you go back to work they're together
they're both being sued together but
they're like they're both wrong they
they committed
the crime together from the other
manufacturer so they're like
they committed the crime together
they're fully partners okay
i think the kodi deal is still it has to
be it's already done okay
okay cool but they need to still make
money so they have to just come up with
new random formulas uh hopefully they're
better
yeah i did have some problems with some
of the kylie products so i'm ready i
always like them at the time but i'm
always
down for you know new formulations
reformulations i do think it'll be
really interesting to see
what happens with the name but it is
like annoying a few times i needed some
restock of some products and i couldn't
go to kylie it's been months
it's crazy she's also now launching
kylie baby we know nothing about it
other than the fact that she created the
instagram and it has 700 thousand
followers and it's never posted anything
before she just tagged like a picture of
stormy with it
um don't know if that's going to be a
cody venture but looking forward to
buying some things for kayla always
looking forward to whatever's next
looking forward to hearing what kim
calls her brand
yeah kk beauty is not great but kim
kardashian kardashian beauty
or like they used to have so many
like makeup lines before like these two
official big ones when they were in like
sears and stuff
they had kardashian beauty they had
kk beauty olivia still has one of their
hair brushes oh
no i think that was like kardashian hair
they just had like so many random lines
they had pretty good [ __ ]
yeah i used their hairspray forever yeah
but that's like og like sears collection
yeah that was licensing deals
that wasn't their own brands so this is
super interesting biz news for sure
super interesting business and i hope
we've shed somebody in the situation for
you
yeah because people were really shook
and i guess if you don't know that piece
of like formula news
you're like oh cool she's rebranding
like who cares no that's really talking
to shut down your site
right no because there's obviously
something bigger going on you don't shut
down your site for like a new logo
yeah totally are you ready for our next
story which is some really sweet news
yeah matt mouser gives a tearful
audition
on america's got talent a year after his
wife christina's death in the helicopter
crashed with kobe bryant
wait what so matt mouser is a man who
auditioned for america's got talent this
week his wife was on
the helicopter with kobe bryant and she
passed away
and he he tried out for america's got
talent because he's like really
passionate about music he's saying and
he's saying oh my god that's so cool
do you want to know what he's saying oh
am i going to cry you might
what against all odds oh my god phil
collins
first of all i absolutely love that song
it's it's really such an underrated song
and we don't talk about it enough
because phil collins's daughter
ruined emily in paris but we should talk
about it more
because it's such a stunning song and
honestly i don't think i can watch this
audition like
i will cry it's it's really emotional uh
spoiler alert he got
the buzzer and he's going through that
is so cute
yeah and he just talks about the year
that he's had and he talked about it on
stage
yeah and it's just so hard it must be
yeah really hard and
just a really beautiful audition so i
think you should watch it i would in
your own time
in my own time i'm just like not in the
headspace for that yet but that's really
sweet i'm sure he was really good too
yeah no he was good and he had said that
um
like before the accident he and his wife
had quit
their job so he could focus on his music
and then she got a job
coaching basketball oh wow um
so that's so sad so sad but just a
really
great story and audition yeah america's
got talent like really
has got talent for sure even though like
do people really get famous off of that
show i don't know anyone who's like
uh i feel like sometimes but no i don't
know
yeah i feel like the age of people going
on like talent shows and becoming famous
is kind of over sometimes it still
happens with the voice
but it's usually not the winner but it's
also not because of the voice it's like
it's because of blake shelton like he
made morgan wallin famous and he made
like raelynn famous
did he make morgan while i'm famous i
don't know or morgan well it's just like
fun fact about him he was on the voice
yeah i'm not sure i don't think he like
don't check me i don't think any
i don't know if any of his success is
from the voice no it's just like so
weird like what has happened to
literally every single person who's won
the voice i don't know and like back in
the day if you want american idol like
that was it like carrie underwood kelly
clarkson even people who didn't win
catherine mcphee
daughtry jennifer hudson daughtry they
didn't even win and they became a star
and then there was x factor fifth
harmony like and then all of that just
kind of stopped
and like the voice and records got
talent are good shows but they didn't
really produce stars like they used to
and i think that that's because the
simon cowell effect like
when you literally like around the music
industry you just like pluck fifth
harmony from the show and put them
i also just think it's a little
oversaturated and like people have so
many things that they could watch
yeah i just think it's when there was
one show
and everybody was watching american idol
but it's not like that anymore i do miss
those days like when we all were a part
of something
yeah and i feel like now it's so hard to
become a part of something
these days then that's why we really
really miss the crisis at the suez canal
we really do we're always thinking of
you yeah
always thinking of suez are you ready
for our next story is it the fifth and
final or the fourth okay it's the fourth
and it's some sad news
what some sad pet news no real
housewives of potomac alum
monique samuels mourns the death of her
pet parrot t'challa
she says the pain is intense no that it
was like
really shocking and i just feel like
monique has had a really hard year with
like you know
being ambushed by andy at the reunion
and none of the women having her back
and then having
to choose to leave the show because it
was so toxic um and t'challa was kind of
like her saving grace i think
and i was really really devastated when
i heard this news just because i know
how
sad monique must have been and she did
say it was a freak accident which is
yeah so sad and like the nosy ass [ __ ]
in me just like kind of wants to know
what happened
yeah well she said on july 1st around 5
pm my entire world was rocked my
t'challa was killed in a freak accident
she went on to write that she can barely
utter his name without crying adding
that the pain of losing t'challa is
indescribable
the pain is intense and i'm just
completely baffled overwhelmed and
cannot stop the emotional rollercoaster
i am on right now
my my children keep breaking down which
makes the pain even worse the kids the
campers
the camera she went on to reference the
incident where to talk to child went
away last august but he came home on his
own she said i had no idea god was
preparing me in that moment for the
unbearable oh my god i'm actually gonna
cry like losing a pet is literally the
worst thing ever
and i just feel like we've all kind of
been on this journey with t'challa like
we met him on the show and then like
post season we were all really invested
when he ran away like there was like
real housewives
support search groups like on the ground
in potomac looking for t'challa
and he flew home and it was like such a
win for us especially a win for monique
when i think she needed it the most um
and i'm just devastated i really do feel
like t'challa is kind of
symbolic of the journey monique has been
on on the show
and that journey is coming to an end and
like i'm just trying to like find some
silver lining like make
a nice speech but it's just terrible
it's
terrible thank you for your sweet words
thank you and i'm really i actually am
like sending a lot of love and
condolences
to t'challa's family and samuel
samuels me too
it's really sad now are you ready
for our fifth and final story is it
colin joseph's carl johansen having a
baby because
you didn't talk about that and i feel
like no i didn't see it anywhere what
it's like the biggest news
i didn't see that well let's talk about
it she's pregnant i think she's like
literally about to give birth like
they're not [ __ ] around where who's
announcing this
page six got the exclusive i'm on page
six and there's been many a whisper
on you know blogs and right i heard the
whispers but to me
that's not like i wouldn't report a
whisper no it's like it's true
yeah okay i see it on page six and she's
like seven months pregnant i guess they
hit it yeah she's
actually due soon yeah so let's talk
about colin jost as a father
okay specifically my father
i am happy for him obviously um but it's
just a rough week for you
yeah like this is again just like
another story kind of
with this narrative that is attacking me
and my happiness and my inner peace and
my joy
because while it's wonderful a baby's
coming into the world and that baby is
going to have
colin jost as a daddy it's hard just
knowing like
i'm not going to be a part of it yeah
and i think a lot of people feel that
and you're not going to be a part of it
in any way
shape or form no like not at all
not at all and i guess that's hard for
you to grapple with yeah and like just
like
watching colin joseph become a father
like i just feel like that would be
really cool to watch and i do wish i was
a part of it like even like
can i be i'll become a doula like you
know
like i just you would be the absolute
worst yeah i'd be like oh
pain yeah oh my god no yeah um well i'm
sorry for you i'm happy for them that i
am sorry for you once again
no and i think that there's definitely a
lot of us like a support group of people
who
are feeling like really happy because
like this has been a really beautiful
journey to watch them
on like 100 i really stand them so hard
as a couple like i have such an enormous
yacht
for them um but as i do with like a lot
of couples that i ship like
i would say 80 20. you know super happy
for them 20
that should be me holding his hand that
should be me
making you laugh that should be me
so happy for you guys what do you think
the baby's gonna be called
claudia i don't know claudia is a really
pretty name
yeah but honestly i don't want it to
become too oversaturated and then i'm
just like one of a million claudia's so
please don't use that name i'm gonna
stop suggesting it to people like that's
always my joke people tell me they're
pregnant i'm like are you gonna name
your baby claudia
that's a really good joke you know it's
like so stupid and no don't [ __ ] name
your baby claudia like we are one of a
kind yeah
i agree i was at a bachelorette party a
few weeks ago with another girl named
claudia and i've never felt more
invisible in my
life like it was actually painful you
know me i'm like so annoying need to be
the center of attention
and like the other girl claudia was like
more well-known amongst a group of
friends than me
you were the lesser claudia every time
someone said claudia i would turn around
like it was not for me and it was so
crazy i was on a bachelor i was humbling
i was at a bachelor party two weeks ago
with another jackie
you were yes and what's so crazy is so
like throughout the weekend i heard
people saying jackie they weren't
talking to me and then we were sitting
truckers for jackie are here thanks guys
love you
uh we were sitting we were having lunch
and everyone was talking about how
there's so many people at the table
with the same names there was like two
samantha's
two jackies two casey's and i was just
like oh my god
i literally didn't even realize that
someone else on the trip had the same
name as me isn't that
because you're so confident like in your
name like even when i heard jackie it
wasn't for me like it didn't register
that like
there's another jackie yeah i feel like
some people it happens to all the time
like
ben suffer like oh my god it's not even
a thing like everyone has the name ben
like if you're living in new york and
you're jewish
like it's just but for me like if you
don't get it a lot it's
very disarming to be in the presence of
someone with the same name as you like
it's actually straight up disrespectful
like you need to leave
yeah but in that situation like you
needed to leave 100 i was like the
lesser of two claudias
and it was devastating yeah that can be
that can be hard
yeah but i'm sure it made you stronger
um
i don't know about that honestly i kind
of just like
was like a self-hate and claudia the
whole the whole weekend oh we hate to
see it but we still have a fifth and
final story that we didn't get to
okay is that okay with you it is i mean
you
you do kind of smell so i think we
should fix that before
i think you need a different segue into
whatever you're gonna say next
okay i think i kind of smell good and i
think before we dive into the fifth and
final story i need to
dash myself in some sunburn i agree have
you ever had someone come up to you and
say you smell amazing what perfume
you're wearing
well whatever scent you may be wearing
you have good taste and you know what
you like
but your great taste is also expensive
and you end up with a shelf full of half
used bottles
with sunbird we have found a way to have
a great taste and mix up our fragrance
routines without breaking the bank
whether it's from tom ford gucci or
versace scentbird.com keeps us smelling
good
month after month because scentbird is a
fragrant subscription service
that makes you that gives you the
opportunity to shop from over 600 brands
it is a flexible subscription so you can
skip any month without penalties
scentbird lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises and they have perfumes and
colognes
for men and women and a lot of unisex
options so you choose the perfume you
want to try they'll send you a 30-day
supply and they carry brands like
product gucci versace
all of them are 100 authentic and if
you're not sure what type of scent
you're looking for
you can go on semper.com and sort and
find a new fragrance based on brand
style occasion season and more
and with an exclusive offer just for our
listeners you can get 30 off your first
month
that's only 11 for your first fragrance
go to scentbird.com
use our code toast for 30 off your first
month that's s-c-e-n-t
bird.com eleven dollars for your first
perfumer cologne
code toast saturn smell amazing
thank you for that claudia you're
welcome now i feel ready to go into our
fifth and final story because you're
gonna need sembered
if you walk into this place
you'll know exactly what i have to say
it's about subway oh
subway is grasping for a lifeline as
americans shun the aging brand
so subway is going for a rebrand
i feel like we just reported on this
like three years ago yeah but no i think
it's gotten worse since three years ago
especially because of coven and
so i'm reading this article it's
actually really interesting you know
there are more subway
locations than there are mcdonald's i
could see that
but um fewer than one in ten subway
stores has drive through so they didn't
they even though like fast food took off
in the pandemic like
subway didn't oh that's majorly stupid
yeah so
they are doing a whole you know revamp
wait i guess they never thought about
that you're right like i actually
have not never but most of the time if i
pass a subway like
not in the city it's always in the
middle of a shopping mall yeah like or
like a
what are those things called where like
all the stores are a shopping center
yeah it's always just like a store front
it's not its own freestanding store
and that's why they don't have
drive-throughs but i guess i never
thought about it until this moment like
subways don't have drive-through
and that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing
they need drive-throughs because if they
had drive-throughs if you had a
drive-through you wouldn't know what
it's like to not walk into something
and smell like subway yeah and that's
the other thing that's the worst part
about subways you can't shake that
subway smell
but a drive-through would solve that no
a hundred percent and two like maybe
they could just solve the smell problem
like where is it coming from
let's eliminate the threat like like we
don't why do we have to build a whole
structure they should get drive-throughs
but why do they have to build a whole
structure just to get rid of the smell
like how much is
you know like clean your toilets or
whatever the [ __ ] that smell is yeah no
it's like the smell of like deli meats
and sandwiches and it's just so
atrocious well that's the other thing i
just want to let you know like the
revamp it's not even about getting
drive-through so it's just like that's
just a reason why they're
different they didn't pop off this year
like so many other chains
they are going with a new biggest change
called the eat
fresh refresh they're rolling out two
new bread recipes several on-trend
premium ingredients
and a handful of new sandwiches plus
nationwide delivery service
it is hoping these changes will alert
diners back to its stores after five
straight years of declines
skeptics of the brand say it won't be so
simple yeah they do need like
gluten-free bread for those freaks
sorry not freaks i know you have celiacs
that was a joke like please celiacs do
not come for me it was a joke
they need vegans vegan options for those
freaks sorry vegans are freaks
um and like they people's diets are
shifting and we're like living in such
you know
specific times where everyone has a diet
and like a lot of people aren't eating
like
sweaty cold turkey and that's just kind
of the same [ __ ] they've been offering
since we were kids and it's really not
cutting it anymore
and it's gross so they just kind of need
a whole
recipe revamp and i think that's what
they're going to try to do but i don't
know it might be too late i feel like
that association with
subway is just already so damaged and
also the
word subway and fresh are just so
in congress one because like subway the
store is like so
gross but also like the subway no nobody
wants to be thinking about
train when they're eating a sandwich i
completely agree the association is
awful yeah and i get that it's meant to
be like
sub sandwiches and it's like this this
way to the subs like i get it it's not
about the train
but i don't think of it as a sandwich
right here subway i think of literally
the train no and i'm sure when they
came up with the name subway they were
like oh and it's like the subway lol
um but then the subway like just took
such a downward
turn yeah that now it's it's hurting the
association but i do want to say it's
not all bad like there are very
redeeming qualities about subway like
the soda machines are excellent and they
do have free refills like let's kind of
lean into that from a marketing space
they have top-notch chocolate chip
cookies like let's lean into that let's
do like a three for one cookie special i
don't know like i don't work in
marketing but
i just feel like they really could be
playing up their strengths while they
work on their
weaknesses aka pretty much everything
behind that plastic screen
right and like people love sandwiches i
feel like there's
such a definitely right and i think even
like mike's jersey subs
does amazing it's amazing so i think
those are two different
franchises jersey mike's and then
jimmy john's yeah jimmy johns is the
other one and they do well but they're
regional subway is national
and i feel like they they put some love
into their products
no they care about the smell of their
stores like
you can't even get in the door at subway
for me no and it's like you have to
literally
wear a hazmat suit because your clothes
will smell like subway for the end of
time
so either get a drive-through so we
don't have to walk in
or get an exterminator no the thing is
like a lot of
mitigation a lot of successful fast food
brands like
the the sheet you're eating like i know
when i'm eating a mcnugget like that
this chicken
fell off the back of a truck like i know
that it's gross but it tastes so good
and like i'm so pleased with the
experience that i really don't care
but when you're eating a subway sandwich
like because it's such a lackluster
disgusting experience like you can't
help but focus on like
where did this turkey come from you know
he literally was abandoned by its
parents
thrown off a truck hit by a bus 20 years
ago
20 years ago had sat in this freezer in
this random subway in minnesota for six
months until
it was thrown out but then some other
subway franchise picked it up like
it's just so glaringly obvious that
you're eating trash where it's like
we all know we're eating trash at
mcdonald's but it's such a fabulous
experience like we couldn't care less
and like
it tastes good so like at the end of the
day that's literally all that matters
yeah and subway does not taste good and
i think we need to talk about it i think
i always
just taste i also just want to like
really recap this segment
with an apology to the vegan and the
gluten-free community like those were
jokes
like 100 and just really not in the mood
for like a pitbull kind of situation
so um i really apologize they were jokes
and i think you're all lovely beautiful
stunning and smart people
and to each their own 100 i'm not
yucking other people's yeah i'm just
like a funny person and i you know i put
others down to be funny and that's
something i'm working on
thank you claudia i think that's really
mature yeah i'm actually not working on
it because it's really funny but um
i'm sorry i really am okay thank you so
much
so that's your subway recap good luck to
you guys i mean maybe with you
fix the taste that'll fix the smell but
it should go
should be top priority for you i don't
have a lot of hope i'm not gonna lie for
this rebrand because they just
i remember we reported they used to be
subway sandwiches right and then they
just became subway like they've
rebranded they got rid of jared
rebranded in like a
branding sort of way just to make it
more modern they got rid of jared as so
they should
yeah and let's not talk about jared and
what he did to the brand right so i do
feel like
even though they they did the right
thing of course separating themselves
from jared
that was kind of irreparable damage yeah
it was like a big [ __ ] stain on the
underwear of subway because you can't
think of like when you go down like the
subway rabbit holes like subway jared
from subway
jar from subway yeah jared from subway
no no no no so they have a lot of work
cut out for them and i'm so glad i don't
work for subway because i don't really
like to work hard
yeah but i think you know if they can do
this they can definitely win some
some ad age awards or something yes yes
yes it's
an opportunity for for a rebranding
agency to win an award
yeah and i guess we really never put
together that subway is one of if not
the biggest
franchises in the country because there
are more of them than mcdonald's crazy
i would have assumed mcdonald's was the
biggest franchise me too just in terms
of location
revenue i'm sure mcdonald's makes more
money than subway yes mcdonald's is
actually delicious michelin star
food yeah because it's not going down
downtown
[ __ ] down down oh i was thinking we're
going down
down any of the songs apply to subway
yeah any and all
okay those are the past five stories i
feel so you needed to know them and why
don't you pick up a subway sandwich
while you're at it
yeah no and um and don't come near me
now i'll type into the tv recap segment
real housewives of new york
so i just want to say like you know
there are people out there your husband
included who
likes like the smell of subway loves
loves like he thinks it's a special part
of the experience of going to subway and
so now i feel like it might be like a
cilantro sort of thing where you either
love it or hate it it's just like in
your
dna i just think like it's better to go
with the safe option if i work at subway
just to get rid of it completely
to get rid of the smell yeah yeah that's
like the smell of gasoline what do you
think about it because i think it's
delicious
it doesn't bother me but you don't like
crave it no i i wouldn't say that i
crave it no but i don't mind it like
it's like ooh gasoline
yeah what about the smaller sharpie i
try not to sniff markers
but if it wafts in my direction
i don't mind it okay um let's dive into
tv recap
the real housewives of new york headed
to
salem which like honestly um and i know
this is going to offend a lot of people
so again
really apologize but this is just my
opinion on my podcast
um i just like hate like spooky
like ghosts like people who are like
obsessed with spirits and like
cemeteries don't get me wrong i
participate in a good seance every now
and then i literally did a ouija board a
couple weeks ago
i like i get the fun of it but people
whose like personalities it is to like
be obsessed with spooky ghosts and like
staging their room like
i just heard that like a really annoying
personality trait and i was just getting
a lot of that energy on the episode last
night
okay i i agree with you generally
speaking i do think that salem is so
rich in history that i can
i can give you okay like i can give a
pass and like it's all part of the story
and that's what you get when you go to
salem and if you watch that movie with
adam
sandler his um halloween movie
what was it called like dewey something
the netflix one yeah i didn't see it
there they live in salem yeah
halloween's like interesting
um then you might have more of an
appreciation for salem that's possible i
just wanted to put it out there like one
of my biggest pet peeves is like
people who are obsessed like spirits and
there was just like i was getting a lot
of that energy you know we get that like
once a season on every house
yeah and it's really annoying i totally
agree stassi used to do it all the time
on vanderpump rules and i like liked
sassy but that whole like i want to get
married in a cemetery like
i just didn't relate to it yeah um and
so i was just getting a lot of that
energy on real housewives of new york
last night and it was
it was frustrating yeah i i agree with
you like spooky but also
i think they're and it's almost like
halloween
it's okay i really liked the part of the
show
where ebony and sonia went to
philadelphia in that
literally luxury ass sprinter van like
that's all i could think about was how
fabulous that was it reminded me of
scott district's mobile office from
media i was just like i didn't know
where they were going yet i thought
maybe they were on their way to salem
and they were going to pick
everyone up in the sprinter and i was
like wow this is so amazing and the
windows were so tinted i was like
is it night are they in the tunnel like
where it was just like so
fabulous and fascinating i completely
and i agree it was a highlight of the
episode for me
yeah like i felt like it was like a safe
space for
sonia to talk about her ex-husband which
like even though she talks about her old
life all the time
i actually don't know that much about
her old marriage yeah and she always
gets cut off
yes so it's like if you just let her
like finish what she wants to say and
also you are going to meet a matchmaker
like your past is important
pertinent to the situation um i agree
like when she's just talking about it
not like um
bragging the morgan ladder right she's
not like off the rails about
it it's interesting yeah because like i
think a lot of people forget
and it's true like sony morgan is like
grey gardens like yeah we get it
but like she lived a life
for a while that was the top one percent
of the one percent it is a life
nobody gets to experience it is the
ultimate wealth
i can't even explain it and like it's a
joke now but i actually would
love when she's like sober and serious
to hear more about that
and i never thought i would say that
because it's like this running joke but
it actually is
really really interesting like she was
basically like a royal of america
morgan rockefeller like yeah it's it's
like a vanderbilt like it's
unbelievable yeah so i actually did
enjoy hearing her speak kind of
coherently about that like
what they used to do together and i just
thought it was really interesting and i
thought like i
really feel like i i like ebony a lot
and part of where
i've really learned to like her so much
is how she is so kind to sonia
and like sees her being like trampled on
by the other women and like we see that
too but it never like
like stuck with me the way it has this
season because ebony pointed it out yeah
sometimes you have to see it through
someone else's eyes in order to realize
what's
what's happening yeah so i thought it
was a really sweet scene and i hope that
it works like
i hope that she got set up with someone
like so fabulous
i it was really cute i agree um and so
then the women arrived in salem in an rv
that honestly was really funny and it
reminds me of the biermanns
rv trip this summer it reminded me of
real housewives of dallas when they took
the rv to
oklahoma yeah it was a cute little
addition like they're all obviously
having to get creative with cobid
yes um and then the episode ended where
they were having drinks and fighting
about politics
in salem and honestly
like ev everyone was just like talking
over each other and i
just sometimes want to like strangle
ramona like
just sit like she makes situations worse
for herself like just sit and like
converse and like you just being so
obviously trying to change the subject
is going to bother
ebony she just let her finish like but
then also i feel like leah is like a
little condescending like i was just i
was everyone was bothering me for
different reasons agreed um
and i couldn't follow even the
conversation then like ramona gets up
and it's like
we wanna just like okay i get that you
don't wanna talk about politics like
every time you make it a big deal like
you make the conversation worse and like
bigger and you make yourself look so bad
like just sit down and nod your head
like have some respect
someone's trying to speak to you about
their experience like just have some
respect
yeah so it was just frustrating it was
frustrating on all counts because
i agree ramona makes things worse for
herself and you're just like
it's ridiculous but then on the other
hand you not everybody needs to talk
about politics so
she can sit there and nod her head but
the other women are
sort of goading her into talking about
politics but a lot of people
that's private for them and it's clear
like that ramona stands on a certain
side politically and she doesn't want to
talk about it but those are her
opinions and they're just trying to kind
of like
expose that in ramona um and she's just
like not giving it to them like at all
and i do think like
if she really does want to avoid the
subject she's not handling it
great i agree i think it's her right to
avoid the subject but she should find
sure she can go about it better
she should go about it better yeah but
all in all like the season is just like
really dragging on um and it's kind of
annoying
i do love bershon like her whole story
about getting cancer is so
crazy oh my god when she was like saying
how you know on the bus
well i think she was saying it in her
confessional like that she or maybe to
the women she was like i had to find out
i was dying in order to wake up and she
was like and now
that i'm awake like nothing and nobody
scares me i'm not gonna
be held back by anything and i was just
like inspired
inspired and moved by that i agree i
love her i actually think she has a lot
of potential
um i'm interested why they because she
does have such a big personality why
they
cast her as a friend of i don't know
when i actually think she has
more than enough of like a dynamic to
like she is friends with ramona yeah why
she shouldn't
just be a full-time cast member because
i actually think i don't know what her
personal life is like but she said she
was married to a british banker like she
sounds like she has stories to tell
right i hope that you know this is just
a trial and that we will see more of her
yeah because she is definitely adding to
the dynamic because it is so boring
and honestly like it's it watchable like
i literally am on my phone for 95
of the episode it's so it's so bad like
i'm just letting you know
if it continues down this way i'm not
going to be
prioritizing watching it and yes i do
know that a watchable is not a word i
just wanted to put that out but when it
comes to real houses in new york
it doesn't matter watchable it's it
honestly is so unwatchable they needed a
new word
um we need a new word
oh oh my we are so over it's over it's
cinderella's right
no we just had ah we just had that
conversation oh my god
my amnesia is getting so bad yeah
um all right dear toasters uh our
segment for advice if you ever want to
write in your toasters at gmail.com is
brought to you by framebridge
frame bridge makes it easier and more
affordable than ever to frame your
favorite things
without ever leaving the house which we
love you can add a gallery wall to your
home office or send the perfect gift
from our prints and diplomas to photo
sitting on your phone you can frame
bridge just about anything
you can frame all the fun memories you
collect this summer from photos ticket
stubs coasters and more
here's how it works go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
they can send you a packaging to safely
mail in a physical photo
you preview your item online in dozens
of frame styles and gallery wall layouts
you choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang and instead of hundreds
you'd pay at the framing store their
prices start at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners can get 15
off their first order at framebridge.com
when they use the code
toast you can also order online at
framebridge.com and stop by a
framebridge store and work with a
designer in person if you're in new york
dc atlanta or philly and they're going
to have storefronts coming in boston and
chicago soon so they're just like really
elevating the framing game which is such
an outdated business
and i'm mad i didn't think of this first
get started today frame your photos or
send someone the perfect gift
at framebridge.com promo code toast to
save an additional 15
off framebridge.com promo code toast
such a great gift idea also like give
yourself the gift of bringing a
beautiful photo
of yourself and putting it in your room
like i have okay because i'm just
constantly inspired by myself
as you should be thank you first up dear
toasters
hi queens hi let's make a long story
short because this one is a doozy
a few months ago my boyfriend convinced
himself i slept with his roommate slash
best friend when all i did was sleep in
on a monday after a bender of a weekend
it's been a bumpy ride but i've been
sticking it out because i love him a lot
and we live together
a couple of my friends are moving around
the city and i have a new housing a few
new housing opportunities
should i decide to end things with my
boyfriend oh no
she phrased this weird a couple of my
friends are moving around in the city
and i have a few new housing
opportunities
should i decide to end things with my
boyfriend that was a weird way
i really don't want to make i really
don't want to
i'm sorry some days i feel like i can't
read
i really don't want to but would kick
myself in the ass if i stay and things
are shitty
we've been working to make things better
but now he wants me to take a polygraph
test
to prove my innocence i'm not worried
that i'll fail but it just sounds like
too much
if you have such little faith in me then
why are we together am i being crazy for
setting this boundary for myself
would you take the test love a remiss
devastated and heartbroken toaster
bye there's the door i will come over
you i will come over and pack your bags
for you you are
literally dating the most paranoid crazy
crazy [ __ ] a polygraph test like
that's nuts he does not trust you
does not does not trust you and things
would only get worse in this regard
you've got to go like even before you
said polygraph i was just like if he's
convincing himself of something like
what else is he gonna he's afraid
himself
but a polygraph test that's when you
know your relationship and he's only
your boyfriend likes
goodbye good day sir is your boyfriend
lisa vanderpump i'm just curious because
only dramatic reality stars in youtube
take polygraph tests
because they also don't even work no oh
right that
um so pack your bags buy a ticket
leave his ass yeah like he's so crazy
like he's like
this is just like a red flag it might
not seem like the biggest deal even
though it kind of is a big deal but it's
such a red flag this leads to such weird
toxic patterns of behavior the first
half was a red flag
yes i'm sorry the first half was an
orange flag
the polygraph is a red flag no we stay
out of these waters stay out of these
waters they are choppy
and turnt do not swim in the sea i was
just gonna say not take risks on
treacherous roads move in with your
friends move it with your friends and
you're gonna have like such a fun hot
girl summer with your friends like
living in a new apartment like get the
[ __ ] out this guy sounds so crazy i just
hope we're making ourselves clear like
we're not
like yeah because i feel like we are
actually when we do relationship
questions we don't always jump to
breakup because i think there are a lot
of things two people can work through
via good communication
a lot of nuance in one issue yes so i
and two sides to every story
so i really don't like to push the red
button like break up but this
is a red button we need a red button for
deer toasters for when it there's no
choice
but to leave yeah all right next up
jackie and claudia
my parents got divorced when i was young
me and my sister daisy were seven and
four respectively
my mom got remarried to my stepdad who
has kids with similar ages
my sister and i grew up having somewhat
of a long-distance relationship with our
step families since they lived across
the country
but every year we would get together and
bond stay in touch
since we've all grown up we continue to
stay connected even though we all live
in different places
for example us siblings go on ski trips
or weekend trips here and there that
sounds so nice like that blended movie
yeah
here's where the dilemma comes in my
sister daisy got engaged recently
yesterday i received a package in the
mail i opened it and i saw a card on top
of
of goodies titled bridesmaid i was like
okay okay i guess this is just a generic
card
i go on to read her card and come to
learn that she is not choosing me for
maid of honor because of quote
the strain it would put on our extended
family
i called her excitedly to accept the
position didn't mention the mate of
honor thing at all and then hung up and
proceeded to bawl my eyes out
eyes out is it wrong to feel like she
should have picked someone
is she really going to choose the
possibility of confrontation with our
stepsister
stepfamily over having a maid of honor
in my biased opinion why would picking
your sister as a maid of honor cause
conflict within the step family
my question to you is do i say anything
or do i just let it be sincerely a
confused toaster
see this is tough because when it comes
to people's weddings like i very much
say like it's not about you like just be
a good friend and like be
be quiet but like i do really i'm
curious like why
this girl daisy would think it would be
offensive to her stepsister
if she chose her um i don't know what
the right word is like full sister
blood sister as her maid of honor like
yeah but i don't know
i get that it's a little bit of a
stretch i'm sure she has her reasons
i just i wouldn't put this much stock in
like this made of honor thing if she had
a friend as a maid of honor and she
didn't choose her sister
i think you could you should could be
upset but like she's not having a maid
of honor
it's such nonsense something it's a fake
job
you know like it's just like a
figurehead position i just
i hate to see you get so upset over
something that really like she's her
sister
i'm assuming you guys have a great
relationship and like nothing no dumb
[ __ ] like this should
should mean more than your actual
relationship
but it makes me sad that you're sad
about it i just
like again it's also her day like it's
really not about you so like
and it's not like she chose someone over
you she just like foregoed having a maid
of honor maybe because we didn't have
made of honors i just don't see the
but i guess because i i like i just
don't care about them because i don't
like i have three sisters so i
that was just never a thing so
i think that people put too much stock
stock and emphasis
on maid of honor and these sort of
titles and positions but you're heard
about it so
i don't think you should make it a big
deal because i don't think it is a big
deal
meanwhile you know i hope you i hope you
can come to terms with it because that's
really sad
yeah i think this is something you need
to work out within yourself yeah like
and not bring it up even though like you
probably are entitled to feel that you
want the way you want to feel
but some battles are just not worth
taking on agree i would argue most
battles are not
agree battles are exhausting and then
you get anxiety like just don't
all right third and final hello queens
and dr theo i've been toasting for just
over two years and i finally need some
words of wisdom sorry that it's so long
it's not long
my boyfriend and i got together just
before quarantine so we didn't spend a
ton of time with our friends in the
start but our state was not as strict as
most
since the middle of last summer we've
spent a lot of time with his group of
friends whom i've really grown to love
but there's always an ex of my
boyfriend's either brought up or
or brought around at first i tried to be
cool i know everyone has a pass but
literally every time we're all together
one of his friends brings up and makes
jokes about people he used to date or
they actually invite these girls to the
bigger events we have like birthdays
baby stuff and most recently the fourth
of july
the fourth of july like the fourth of
july
now i know everyone has a history but at
this point it's getting old and they
never truly make an effort to be kind to
me
with me being the newest one to this old
group of friends they'll literally say
to him and not me
and sorry they'll literally say hi to
him and not me and essentially pretend i
don't exist
i told my boyfriend that at least a
heads up would be nice that these other
women will be there and he agrees but
it's not like his friends really give
him a heads up either
as a result i really don't want to be
part of their summer but i don't want to
keep my man from his friends
either how do i go about getting some
respect from these women or how do i not
care so much about them being around
sincerely a fed up toaster i just want
to say one thing
i hear you say that you hang out with
his group of friends and you've grown to
love them
i just want to know what's to love about
this group they sound really [ __ ]
mean and like so immature like
like remember when shep brought that
girl austin out of threesome with to
that party in southern charm like
that is giving me that kind of energy
and that was so mean when shep did it so
i don't know why you've grown to love
this group of men who literally have no
respect for you or your relationship
and i would be really annoyed too and i
wouldn't go around saying that i love
his group of friends because you
shouldn't
no you shouldn't this would bother me of
every right to be upset
and i i mean it seems like these people
are really immature two-year-olds like
growing up
you and your boyfriend are mature and
like just in a different place in your
life
and i think you need to like
make small changes to remove yourself
from these situations like find
alternative plans like tell like and
make it clear to your boyfriend like we
could hang out with your friends more if
they didn't suck like
you can work on your friends not sucking
and then we can hang out like i think
you need to put your foot down because
this is so disrespectful
and at a certain point it reflects
poorly on your boyfriend yeah
like the company hang with dogs you get
fleas
yeah lie with the dogs yeah but they're
hanging yeah well the thing is is also
i think this is something that happens a
lot like when your group of friends
have been friends like since middle
school you have this like really stupid
immature kind of vibe and like even
though you grow up that silliness never
goes away and sometimes i feel like
when i hang out with people i've known
forever like i act silly but it's fun
because like
i don't hang out with them all the time
and when your go-to group of friends is
people you've known since middle school
you just kind of like revert like middle
schoolers you revert back to that level
of maturity and it's actually really
unhealthy like for real so
i think this is something a lot of
people probably deal with when hanging
out with people that they've known
forever
and if that's your go-to group of
friends it can be really toxic so i
think you need to
definitely remove yourself from this
group of friends find people in your
town who are like uh grown up and
elevated maybe other people who are in
relationships so they can like relate to
the type of problems
you're having and it's really hard to
make new friends as a grown-ass woman
so i would you know join like a toaster
group in your area like there are so
many ways to meet new people
yeah there are so this is definitely
like by
material yeah and i would just say like
if you're ever forced to be around them
again and like some
like they're just like being animals and
immature just like be a
big bad [ __ ] like
totally fire with fire fight fire with
fire like towards the men if these girls
are acting disrespectfully it's like
exes or
these girls or you could sometimes you
catch more
flies with honey than you do with
vinegar if these girls are
sent there to like [ __ ] with you become
their best friend
no naturalize the threat but see but but
first decipher like how how are they
acting are they trying to come on to
your man or they just happen to be there
i think like they just got invited to a
party by their friends from high school
like of course they're gonna come
and the boys are doing it with malicious
intent but it's really not the girl's
fault
right so maybe you neutralize the threat
and you all become best friends and the
boys look like dumb ass
no but then it's like she's letting them
win like i think you should be a bit i
like your first advice like be a big bad
[ __ ]
to the boys like no but then they want
to want to like have you around
you're good you don't want to be around
yeah no i just think you need to remove
yourself from the situation
and start inviting their exes around and
then also invite their moms
too so they can see how they behave
jackie i
love that idea sometimes the best way to
get to someone is to tell their mom what
they're doing because
people who have good relationships and
like respect their moms like
don't want to get in trouble from
parents and like some moms can be scary
so like
i think that tattling to their moms is
the best idea you've ever had
yeah that's a good that's a good go-to
sometimes i think about like
literally calling people's parents like
it's such a thrill you are like when
someone's like being a troll on the
internet like i just want to find their
parents and like
send them what they're saying and be
like are you aware your child is
behaving in this manner no and i just
think it's something they should know
yeah i love that idea i think we should
tell their parents as well yeah
um and those were the do your toasters
if you ever want to write into your
toasters the email account is dear
toasters gmail.com
you can write in about anything we will
always keep you anonymous you can change
people's names
whatever um and if you've written into
us recently and we've read your prompt
on air
let us know how it's going we'd love to
hear from you in an update did you take
our advice did you not take our advice
did things get better did things get
worse
and we'll be happy to share that on air
and besides that that's our show
that is our show everyone enjoy your
hump day your church or the hump
someone you love and have a great day
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast monday morning show where
we deliver the festive stories that you
need to know every monday friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also always podcasting
where podcasts can be found so spotify
isn't such a trouble radio where already
guess what all the voices
podcasts find out someone just said fast
forward you better beautiful signings
hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for thursday's
show goodbye goodbye
you